[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لندن ابنه لوندون الروماني تظل تحافظ على
بقايا الحجر الامبراطوري وتتقلب على مرمى
منه بين الشروق والغروب من هنا من جرينتش
تقسم لندن العالم نصفين كما تريد هناك نصف
ضد روسيا بالقوه ونصف اخر مع اوكرانيا
بالفعل منذ ان بدات الشمس تنحسر على
مستعمراتها اصبحت لندن تفضل الاشعاع
الامريكي على ما تبقى من بصيص الانوار
الاوروبيه البريكزت اطلق من جديد عنان
التفكير السياسي الانجلو امريكي بعيدا عن
الفكر القاري الاوروبي ولكن الحرب الروسيه
على اوكرانيا اعادت الجنوح البريطاني الى
سواحل اوروبا في اطار الحلف الاطلسي موسكو
هي الفزاعه التي ترقبها لندن منذ قرون الى
الايام الاخيره في اوكرانيا بدات العلاقات
منذ حكم ايفان الرهيب الذي منح التجار
البريطانيين الكثير من المزايا والاعفاءات
الى ان فكر في الزواج من الملكه اليزابث
الاولى التي
[موسيقى]
صدت لم تكن العلاقات بين البلدين وطيده
وان كانت قديمه تعود الى ايفان الرهيب
والملكه اليزابت بريطانيا تبقى نائيه عن
روسيا جغرا
وسيكولوجيا علاقه بريطانيا وروسيا امتدت
على مدى قرون واتسمت بتوليد التحالفات
والحروب تغيرت الاحداثيات اكثر من مره حيث
كانت بريطانيا منهمكه في اللعبه الاوروبيه
ولكن في العصر الحديث دائما ما يكون بين
روسيا وبريطانيا ثالث هو غالبا امريكا
امريكا منذ ان كانت مستعمره بريطانيه وهي
موضوع جدل بين روسيا وبريطانيا فقد حصل ان
طلب الملك جورج الثالث من يكاترينا
الثانيه ترسل الجنود الروس لقمع
الامريكيين الثائرين من اجل
استقلالهم رفضت الامبراطوره واسست جامعه
الحياد المسلح في البحار ضد القرصنه
البريطانيه توالت بعد ذلك التحالفات
والحروب بين الجانبين بما في ذلك التحالف
ضد نابوليون فحرب القرم وصولا الى
الاحتلال السوفيتي البريطاني المشترك
لايران خلال الحرب العالميه الثانيه قبل
ذلك جرت اللعبه الكبرى بين البلدين على
اراضي اسيا الوسطى اصبح مصطلح اللعبه
الكبرى دارجا بفضل الكاتب البريطاني
الهندي المولد روديارد كيبلينغ الذي لخص
انشطار العالم بقوله الشرق شرق والغرب غرب
وهما لا يلتقيان كيبلينج الذي وصفه
بريطاني اخر هو جورج اورويل بنبي
الامبراطوريه البريطانيه اورويل الذي اشاع
مصطلح الحرب البارده في مقالته القصيره
انتم والقنبله
النوويه بالقرب من خط جرينتش اتم حزب
العمال الاشتراكي الديمقراطي الروسي
انعقاده في لندن وهناك انقسم المشروع الى
[موسيقى]
بلاشفة في طهران ويالا وبوتس دام وهناك
خطه للنصر وتقاسم العالم بمجرد ان انفض
السامر خسر المنتصر تشرش ال انتخاباته
وتفرغ لعداء ستالين ورفاقه اصبح الرجل
يدعو الى نسف موسكو بالسلاح النووي وهناك
من ينسب الى الفائز بجائزه نوبل للاداب
الجمله المجنحه التي يشبه فيها الكرملين
بالسجاده التي تتعارك تحتها كلاب من فصيله
البولدوج قبل الاحتفال بالذكرى الاولى
المصري على النازيه اعطت شرشل الاشاره
برفع الستار الحديدي بين المعسكرين في
خطابه الشهير بمدينه فولتون
الامريكيه وكانه كان بذلك يعطي الاشاره
لتراجع دور بريطانيا لحساب الامبراطوريه
الجديده طوال الحرب البارده
وبعدها منذ ذلك التاريخ ستاخذ العداوه بين
لندن وموسكو شكل حرب استخبارات بالسم
وغازي نوفيتشوك كما يقال في الاثناء ظل
هاملت شكسبير يملا المسارح السوفيتيه
بسؤاله الابدي وارتفعت الحان ورولين ستونز
وبينك فلويد في الهامش السوفيتي الى ان
انهار وانفتحت الابواب وظن الغرب ان
اللعبه الكبرى انتهت ولكن بوتين برز من
بين شطحات يلتسين وخيب ظن المتفائلين
اعادت الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا زخم
العداوه بين موسكو ولندن وملات الاختلاف
بشحنه جعلت بريطانيا من اشد الداعمين
والداعين الى نجده كيف وتصريف العداء
التاريخيه عبر القنوات
الاوكرانيه في اوروبا الان قلق من الحرب
الناس بداوا يتعبون من تقديم الدعم
لاوكرانيا صحيح ان الغرب يبقى متحدا ولكن
هناك تباين في المواقف بريطانيا اشد موقفا
قد تكون الحرب على اوكرانيا في حاجه الى
مفكرين روس من امثال ليفت تستوي واندر ساخ
يغلبون السلم على الحرب وفي حاجه الى
بريطانيين من امثال كيبلين واويل ليشرح
اللعبه الكبرى الراهنه ويحذر العالم مره
تلو اخرى انتم والقنبله النوويه
بين بريطانيا وروسيا هناك دائما لعبه كبرى
لعبه امبراطوريه خطيره لا تتوقفوا وان
تغيرت ميادينها في القرن التاس عشر كانت
افغانستان وما حولها الميدان في القرن
العشرين قسم ستارها الحديدي العالم نصفين
اما الان فقد انتقلت هذه اللعبه الكبرى
الى اوروبا نفسها وعلى ما يبدو فان
اوكرانيا هي الشوط الحاسم جمال العرضه
الجزيره لندن
بريطانيا